one of las vegas most iconic sports
bettors died early this morning
sports bettor lem banker passed away
chris matthews shares decades of winners
and losers with the man that many simply
just knew as lem
right here on channel 8 we're reserved
for lim banker as he shared his sports
picks and jokes with our viewers
and how can we forget that annoying
jingle take a look
at them
hi channel h4 fan slim banger checkers
banker was one of the country's most
respected sports bettors before
computers
he had runners all over the country
getting him inside information on teams
players and injuries stuff that nobody
else had and he put his money down
if you like favorites play early if you
like underdogs
banker wasn't perfect not even close but
he won more than he lost and loved life
and family more than most
probably the most important thing in my
whole life and my my honesty and my
integrity you know
i've never compromised that he had a
heart of gold and a passion for numbers
his was a hard profession and many times
would say to us never get involved in
sports betting
90 percent of the people that bet
football
are going to lose he lived it loved it
it was his only job
ever he was an old school las vegas he
knew the good guys the bad guys the
mobsters entertainers and athletes mike
tyson showed up at his birthday party
man in the old fight he's been backed up
with joe lewis and sam langford
another charles man i just like to come
here and pick his brain limb
seemingly knew every mover and shaker in
las vegas his best friend was boxing
champion sunny liston and he was a real
good friend with raiders legendary owner
al davis
with the business of winners and losers
here's our good friend lam banker
two things i proudes my honesty and my
integrity you know and
and meeting all the united people from
channel 8.
let's see what games are in channel 8.
so on sunday it's a good bet lim is
betting on the raiders
go out and win one for lamb guys he's
our good friend gone
at the age of 93 so from all of us here
at channel 8
rest in peace lem banker yeah chris had
a long relationship with him thank you
chris certainly a true las vegas icon
funeral services for lamb are still
being arranged right now most likely it
will be the week after thanksgiving
what a wonderful tribute there thanks
chris